in the quantum universe there's an
undiscovered frontier where the laws of
our world give way to the ones that
apply on the tiniest scale we know
they're divorced from our everyday
experience how can you think about a
world that has different rules than ours
it's not easy that's why I want to take
you to this place where it's not only
possible to make such a leap it's
mandatory it's a world very much like
our own except in one respect
[Music]
it just happens to be missing a spatial
dimension the third one in order to
venture into the quantum cosmos we have
to be able to imagine another dimension
that's very hard to do it's much easier
to wrap your mind around a world that's
missing one of the three dimensions that
we take for granted the beings of the
world we're about to enter have only two
this world was first imagined by a man
named Edwin Abbott everyone and
everything here and everyone they know
and love is flat their houses are flat
some are squares others are triangles
some have more complex shapes say
octagons but all are completely flat
they scurry about on foot or in little
vehicles in and out of their flat
buildings busy with their flat lives
everyone on this world has width and
length but no height whatsoever these
flat worlders know about left right and
forward back but have no hint not an
inkling about up-down except for one
tiny group the mathematicians who
imagine something more
the mathematicians dream of a world in
three dimensions but it's too hard for
most of the flat world errs to think
about the mathematician says listen it's
really very easy we all know left-right
we all know forward back so let's just
imagine another dimension at right
angles to the other tune but the flat
world errs say what are you talking
about at right angles to the other two
everybody knows that there can only be
two dimensions go ahead wise guy show us
that third dimension where is it so the
mathematician draws a picture poor
teacher nobody listens to mathematicians
[Music]
every creature on flat world sees its
fellows as merely short lines which are
the nearest sides of their oblong bodies
but the insides of a flat world er are
forever mysterious unless exposed by
some terrible accident or autopsy and
then one day we came hello how are you
hi I'm a visitor from the third
dimension hello I feel sorry for the
little guy to him it appears that my
greeting is emanating from his own flat
body an alien voice from within that's
because nothing can come from above
there is no above in this world a
three-dimensional creature like me can
only exist on flat wolf where my feet
touch the surface of the plane
sorry little guy I know how weird this
must be for you don't worry
got a perfectly safe trip to a third
dimension nothing's gonna harm you but
this is your chance to see a whole new
perspective on where you live at first
our flat world er can make no sense of
what is happening just utterly outside
the realm of flat world experience but
eventually he realizes that he's viewing
flat world from a totally new vantage
point above now he can see into closed
rooms he can see into his flat fellows
this unprecedented the 3-dimensional
view of his two-dimensional universe is
devastating traveling to another
dimension provides as an incidental
benefit a kind of x-ray vision just as
the flat world houses can have no roofs
their inhabitants can have no sky
because that sky could only exist in a
third dimension little guys suffered
enough that put them down
from the point of view of its spouse
this flat world er has distressingly
disappeared than unaccountably
materialized from out of nowhere
[Music]
[Music]